president biden proving once again he's
got no clue when it comes to the
pandemic some of his top former medical
advisors are trying to get his attention
saying the president's covid strategy
needs a major overhaul and one biden to
tell americans they need to learn to
live with it
good luck with that the
commander-in-chief contradicting himself
in the same sentence while talking about
his covet plan and what americans can
expect
[Music]
uh no i don't think covert is here to
say that having
coveted in the environment here and in
the world is probably here to stay but
covet as we're dealing with it now
is not here to stay the new normal
doesn't have to be we have so many more
tools and so
we're going to be able to control this
the new normal is not going to be what
it is now it's going to be better
and if you thought jimmy carter was bad
kamala harris is trying to one-up him
the vp not inspiring any confidence with
these comments about dealing with the
virus
and i understand and i fully appreciate
there is a level of of malaise
we're in two years into this thing
you know people are that we want to get
back to normal we all do
but we have to to then do the tough and
hard work of pushing through
with solutions understanding that there
are going to be challenges
and biden's sweeping vax mandates could
be on the ropes the supreme court
hearing challenges to the mandates today
and signaling they could strike them
down
all right let's
just mention
greg brought
what are we calling this thing uh
america's fish that's america's fish
erica's fish it's
can we get a close-up of him uh i called
you know outnumbered has one lucky guy
this is one lucky gill
and you know he's just dying to school
geraldo oh sophie doesn't get hooked on
the spotlight but you know i figured
since i'm alone all the in the studio i
needed somebody to keep me company and
who better than my little friend abe
he's adorable look at those eyes
sexy little fish watch watch yourself we
could have an hr complaint
all right greg take it away well you
know what
we're in desperate need for leadership
and something that's called wisdom and
there's nothing that joe has said joe
biden has said that provides any of that
which is weird because that's the
benefits of age is wisdom but instead
we're getting the consequences of age
which is a disjointed convoluted aimless
asides about things and and i go back to
that original thing that i said a long
time ago
it's the people who are going to lead us
out of this not the leaders and you
could you talk to anybody because of
this bad messaging and the exhaustion
and people with the the boosters and the
double boosters getting covered people
have it's almost miraculous people are
actually in unison having enough they've
had enough they're looking at february
1st they know that's when this is going
to be over it's almost like we are
leading the country not the leaders the
problem with kamala harris so she is the
911 of pearl harbors right
she's she's on what scientists call poop
island it's a place that once you get on
it you can't get off and everyone who's
supposed to help you doesn't want to
because they don't want any poop on them
so basically they're just letting her
suffer and it's so unfair to jimmy
carter because he never said malaise
he it was a because the speech was a
crisis in confidence but he never said
malays but it's called the malay speech
but you get the sense that the dems have
given up on kamala and joe it's like a
dead marriage that it's kept alive until
the kids are out of the house and in
this case if the kid's out of the house
is when the election comes up
all right so when geraldo
greg mentioned with age comes wisdom so
we'll go to you but yeah kamala harris i
resemble i resemble those remarks yes
kamala harris should should know better
not because she's old but or because she
was around in the 70s because she's a
politician you know you don't say the
word malaise it just it triggers the
carter era it makes people remember the
era it's not a great era why did she say
that and why
how could she say that
i think in terms of communication she
really is clueless and i say that with
all due respect and i really always
remind myself and everyone else that
what a historic figure uh she is but uh
welcome back carter uh you know it's uh
to use that word invokes the era you
know uh biden's covid is carter's
hostage crisis
and this feeling america has a
simultaneous case of the blahs now and
it it may be just the fact that you know
i got sick a couple of weeks ago and
that that that tinted uh or tinged my my
optimism that i usually have kind of
buoyant person naturally but i really
it's kind of snowing in cleveland you're
kind of dragging your uh your tail
through life uh wondering when when this
thing's finally gonna end and you can go
to the airport when you want to and you
know give someone a high five when you
want to it's uh it's a lot it's a lot uh
and the news is uh is pretty mediocre
generally speaking jesse you know deagon
it was a great analogy by geraldo that
that covid is joe biden's
hostage crisis um
would you like to add anything to that i
think it sums it up pretty perfectly
now i would like to uh
well i think i've kind of given up hope
after i was listening
or read and reading what the liberal
supreme court justices said
and the
misinformation
that they were hacking up how can you
make good
sound policies and decisions when you're
using
the wrong incorrect information you
cannot justice sotomayor said 100 000
children are in serious condition many
on ventilators
wrong
there there are fewer children who have
been hospitalized with covet in the last
year and a half it's about 84 000.
another doozy omicron is as deadly as
delta no it's not not even for the
unvaccinated it's not i called doctors
about this they said that is patently
false marty mccary the doctor told me
there are actually no confirmed deaths
from omicron not even the original one
in houston justice bright so
you have a supreme court justice justice
breyer went on to say implied omicron
case numbers would start falling if the
biden vaccine mandate was in place well
that's balderdash and then elena kagan
was taught essentially talking about
this policy the vaccine mandate we
needed we need this to stop the virus we
need to stop the spread with this
vaccine vaccinated people are catching
it
look at geraldo and me and all of us and
spreading it so i just want to point out
you have a supreme court justice
particularly sotomayor that was the most
egregious today on the most important
issue facing this nation
and she has her facts not just wrong
but stunningly pick up my jaw off the
floor wrong so it's like she's getting
her facts from cnn or even the view
joy behar would have done a better job
on the high court today justice behar
that is a shocking image martha how
stunning is it that you have
supreme court justices the president the
vice president the cdc not able to speak
with any sort of precision
about a virus that you think by this
point we'd know a little something about
yeah i think that americans as a nation
we just have a certain level of
expectation for how smart we're going to
be about things and how well we're going
to handle stuff we expect that i looked
up the numbers today how much we spend
on hhs and combined with the um naid the
national uh you know allergen infectious
disease and nih right so you've got
about 2 trillion and then another 50
billion dollars right and then you have
this letter that comes from these six
very esteemed doctors and one of the
suggestions that they have is that the
united states should have a modern data
infrastructure to surveil the virus
hello i mean wouldn't you have a natural
expectation in the technologically
advanced united states of america that
we wouldn't have to call on israel and
the uk to figure out the data for how
long the immune system is able to fight
off these different viruses after the
vaccines why how could we possibly be
spending over two trillion dollars and
employing thousands of people at these
health agencies what are they doing if
they're not figuring out a modern data
infrastructure to know more about the
virus and feel smart about it instead
you have this sort of
i compare it to like the peanuts teacher
want
right coming from the top levels of our
government talking about challenges that
we'll face and tough things that will
come and how we'll work through the
problems and you just say no i want
actual results i want as an american
citizen to say well i know that there
are monoclonal antibodies out there and
i know that there are treatments out
there so i would certainly expect that
if someone needed them they would be
able to get their hands on them in the
united states of america so these are
really specific things that i think
americans just have an expectation that
we're going to handle well and we
haven't so it doesn't matter how many
times you're told like gee we get it you
know there's a little bit of malaise and
wa we want more than that and we should
have more than that for the money that
we spend a pagoda america's fish would
do a better job
can i say something about egg pagoda yes
i love that name all right so i i
actually know why
greg named it a pagoda and i took a poll
nobody else knew so i was kind of proud
of myself but i know why i wrote down in
the elevator with abe vegota yes able to
go to smells but did he smell was he
polite to you he didn't say anything to
you in the elevator like
he was trying to look up my skirt oh
i'm just kidding
i think it's just because
we're gonna have to put him in the
sensitivity training
all right that's next week hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else